there wasn't a lot of smiley faces with
me out there there wasn't a lot of
smiley faces with Michael Jordan there
weren't a lot of smiley faces with Tiger
Woods
right tiger wasn't trying to be friends
with anybody tiger had no friends
Tiger's friends were guys that he knew
he could kick their butt those were
Tiger's friends
and they were very happy to have their
butts kicked by Tiger Wood and be his
friend so tiger had him right where he
wanted them and I think for me like even
when I watched sports today and I see
like golf's a good example I see these
guys on the Range yeah like they're all
buddies and their caddies are friends
and I'm like that's not the Killer
Instinct that's just not I don't I don't
know how you can wanna crush the
competition because they are your
competition but then they're like have
dinner with them the next night yeah